[Musique]
à bas les amis aujourd'hui on va jouer
aux jeux verts qui a le plus besoin et
cette année par l'année dernière du coin
2010 est sévère chat singer dans lequel
on va pouvoir choisir notre avatar on va
pouvoir aller de monde en monde dans
lesquels il ya des trucs différents
affaires et rencontrer d'autres joueurs
et leur parler et peut-être ensuite se
voir dans la vraie vie boire un verre
vraiment créer une amitié durable tout
ça grâce à du virtuel c'est magnifique
en gros c'est un peu un site de
rencontres nouvelle génération où tu le
vois les gens dans le jeu mais ils ont
choisi un avatar dont qui reste anonyme
j'ai vu mille trucs sur ce jeu j'ai
toujours eu trop envie de jouer mais
j'ai jamais fait le pas parce qu'il faut
parler anglais vu que c'est des gens qui
viennent du monde entier pour que tout
le monde puisse le comprendre pour
parler anglais connaissez mon skill en
anglais vous en faites pas je suis allée
48 heures à lourdes avec mon frère via
trois jours dont allemand très bien se
passer c'est parti alors premièrement on
va choisir ensemble l'avatar donc là on
ressemble à ça j'aimerais bien qu'on a
un truc un peu plus original le genre un
biker rba on est mieux ou pas ça c'est
excellent ok je vois mes jambes je vois
mes mains et je peux changer les
expressions de les mains aux fesses peut
faire 2 je peux faire ça et un pouce
voilà donc on entend les autres gens
dans le jeu et ne nous entendent aussi
et on se déplace avec le joystick et en
fait quand on se déplace on se voir se
déplacer voilà et quand j'arrête hop je
me retrouve à l'endroit où mon avatar
était voyez hop voilà c'est tout c'était
explication la plus simple et la plus
efficace
ensuite tu choisis le monde dans lequel
tu vas y à une chiée de monde
the great buck je crois que ça c'est le
monde de base soit c'est un peuple et
une somme toutes les ressources de mon
cerveau sont disponibles pour parler
anglais
c'est stressant où charmant alors ayew
le spectacle est donc moyennement et
vous partez mec sait trop bien puisque
ce système là pour se déplacer tout
donne pas la gère donc c'est un vrai
plaisir à tanger ou là dans la vraie vie
ok j'entends des gens parler aux vallées
bondi beach d'une structure à l'examen
au sénat
[Musique]
amyot in the game the new american idol
trois femmes politiques hockey à gaza ne
[Musique]
sais quoi de votre club ché curieux avec
la musique c'est chiant on va aller à la
chambre des présentations et la bay'a
canaille thatcher l'ipl3 hockey comme
metop les fournisseurs riou you have to
kingdom and let me tape sur l'épaule
it will be good for you let your turn
into you eat your destiny you have to
let me thatcher n'est pas l'école itouch
et lettres methods and war la passionne
des vols
[Musique]
johansson twilight l'ocré this is never
hide the smell like the spaghetti tout à
fait qu'ils peuvent être activés je veux
toucher d'été de avatar testing chasse
amont dans lesquelles ils testent des
avatars on va aller voir ça et là au new
age single level cell and ashes marie au
quai des nanomatériaux saint-honoré au
terminal 2d rice en espèces sauf chez
touch au litre boom and white
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là où ce jeu m'a nommé m we can you may
be ok
on n'allait pas vrai
encore du tgcc 200 ch et non et non à la
question vous plaise ou non
bruce hack 'n question mais oui ce qui
la lie au monde dont le japon c'est bon
ça c'est fini nous cei bonsoir cei fils
de [ __ ] essaye de you want you go away
with me you say nique ta mère équipée
aké n'gbo
et elle tient pas au shit my god et puis
si ça lui ça va on fait une rencontre
abonnés d'angers beaucoup vient de faire
un câlin avant que j'aille dans un autre
monde vient de faire un câlin bien la
wheego qu en tout cas c'est la plus sûre
de 30 mètres bah écoute pareil mike tu
te fais de gros bisous et josh holloway
aux poteaux en bois oneway new style so
you la séborrhée sais je suis moi écoute
un micro normalement il y en a je me
fais stolic et c'est toi qui me stalk
non non si tu me suis dans les mondes où
je vais je t'ai entendu dire comme ton
micro genre gestu must hot tub ostende
anvers et la fox à nam nam les les yeux
ugo rondinone stop de chinon look at you
know i'm your father budget mais because
it was in time ago and go now you is
your mother follow me lisent
oui si les âmes sensibles shizuoka au
mausolée du arthur accepte de tuer
michael thomas hocquet nice lise sweety
please give you do you have to accept
our game mais qu'est ce qui me guide to
your face à nice oil family it was the
night and day dubai
adroit la world is my family life as we
know garbage hockey entre lisbonne d'ici
c'est tout ce temps menez les médioni de
doliprane quelle guigne au doliprane et
[Musique]
des border collie médiévaux et oiseaux
praille les amis c'est la fin de cette
vidéo sur verre chat je crois que j'ai
jamais tourné aussi longtemps réellement
je crois que ça fait 3 heures que je
tente j'ai pas vu le temps passer par
mes yeux l'ont jugée très mal aux yeux
réellement mec c'est trop drôle je fais
des rencontres improbables ya des
situations improbables qui tombe sur des
trucs improbable c'est génial j'adore
découvrir des gens d'ailleurs sur le
monde et parler avec eux alors qu'ils
sont à des milliers de kilomètres de moi
ou les voir dans le jeu comme s'ils
étaient vraiment là je trouve ça
vraiment génial enfin bon j'ai trop
kiffé tout simplement voilà j'ai pas
aimé la vidéo et à me dire si vous
voulez d'autres épisodes et puis en tout
cas je vous fais plein de bisous et
jeudi attribués dans une prochaine vidéo
au revoir les vols
[Musique]